si la parole à monsieur francis delattre
pour le groupe ump ce
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur glisse du budget
dans un grand fracas médiatique monsieur
gallois nous proposer ici même le 7
novembre dernier de créer un choc de
compétitivité en transférant 30
milliards des charges sociales des
entreprises via la fiscalité à parité à
50% aussi sur les économies du secteur
public la loi de finances 2013 est déjà
beaucoup plus modeste elle ramené le
chiffre à 20 milliards et après bien des
discussions nous avions compris que pour
l'année 2013
l'objectif était de 10 milliards
d'allègements
réellement inscrits dans les comptes des
administrations publiques
le rapport gallois en ces préconisations
semblait indiquer une prise de
conscience du gouvernement des effets
négatifs de sa politique économique
fondée dans les six premiers mois
essentiellement sur des prélèvements et
parfois même sur la stigmatisation des
entrepreneurs près de six mois après les
annonces où en sommes-nous mes chers
collègues pour 2013 le préfinancement
est effectué assez curieusement par la
banque publique d'investissement se
chiffre aujourd'hui ce gif à 660
millions et d'après le patron le
directeur général de cette institution
confirmée par le directeur du budget le
chiffre de 2 milliards sera un maximum
pour l'année 2013 vous comprendrez donc
entre 10 milliards et 2 milliards il y a
quand même là un vrai problème avec la
boîte à outils qui se révèlent parfois
est une véritable boîte à malice le
crédit d'impôt compétitivité reste
aujourd'hui monsieur misera grand flou
budgétaires notamment sur les économie
affectée puisque la moitié de son
financement c'est sur les économies mais
l'expérimentation en cours on peut
mesurer des gens la pac réel du
dispositif 6 quels sont les salariés
concernés l'absence de dégressivité de
la limite de 2 5% du smic conduit en
réalité un blocage des salaires moyens à
2,49 smic l'entreprise obtient 1700
euros dégrèvement à 2,51
aucun smic malgré une instruction
fiscale de 40 d'une page les entreprises
ont des difficultés à calculer entre les
primes le treizième mois les abattement
pour frais professionnels a calculé un
véritable smic annuel alors deuxième
interrogation quelles sont les
entreprises qui bénéficient puisque
c'était l'industrie qui était visé
essentiellement en tête des
bénéficiaires la grande distribution 3
milliards d'euros les grandes
entreprises de travaux publics 2
milliards d'euros on peut dire qu'elles
sont peu délocalisables par rapport aux
entreprises en difficulté monsieur le
ministre qui s'en occupe et sa chaire
cholet qu'il faut arriver à la question
vivant et passez votre temps lâche 100
millions d'euros à comparer avec 15
c'est aussi dangereux entre 110 et 188e
le ministre l'objectif de la
réindustrialisation à cette mesure n'est
pas atteint j'aurais savoir quelles
mesures il compte prendre pour y
remédier c'est bien la parole à monsieur
bernard 15,9 ministre chargé du budget
c'est le sénateur merci pour votre
question qui est l'occasion de faire un
point sur les conditions de mise en
oeuvre du crédit d'impôt compétitivité
emploi et de l'ensemble des mesures qui
sont prises pour favoriser le retour à
la compétitivité de notre secteur
productif je voudrais vous apporter une
réponse la plus précise possible
concernant les dispositifs mis en oeuvre
depuis l'instruction de février 2002 mai
2013 à laquelle vous faites référence
pour faire en sorte que cette mesure
soit rapidement présentés par les
entreprises d'abord cette mesure est
simple s'inspire de mesures antérieures
qui avaient été prises par d'autres
gouvernements que vous souteniez à
l'époque elle est un ex temps une
extension du crédit d'impôt elle permet
aux entreprises en ligne de bénéficier
immédiatement de la mesure elles
pourront comptabiliser cette mesure dès
2013 pour améliorer leurs comptes
d'exploitation elles pourront le faire
aussi pour faire baisser dès 2013 leurs
prix pour celles d'entre elles qui sont
soumis à la concurrence internationale
elles pourront aussi pour un certain
nombre d'entre elles qui sont en
difficultés de trésorerie
bénéficié de l'effet du crédit d'impôt
non seulement en comptabilité mais
immédiatement comment peuvent elles
faire nous avons mis en place un
dispositif auprès de la bpi qui permet à
ces entreprises en ligne de pouvoir
bénéficier dès 2013 de ce crédit d'impôt
cela représente à peu près 500 à 600
millions d'euros de mobiliser mais nous
avons souhaité aller au delà et pierre
moscovici a signé une convention avec la
fédération française des banques avec le
secteur de l'entreprise avec notre
ministère pour que les banques elles
mêmes puissent ouvrir la possibilité sur
les territoires d'accès à ce crédit
d'impôt pour les entreprises de leur
ressort cela est rendu possible par un
mécanisme de garanties offertes par la
bpi qui la montée permettent la montée
en puissance de la mesure au cours de
l'année 2013 enfin vous interroger et
d'ailleurs vous est légitime à le faire
la question est intéressante elle est
légitime pour les entreprises certaines
d'entre elles nous interroge sur la
portée de cette mesure par rapport à
d'autres dispositifs d'allégements de
charges je veux simplement vous rappelez
sans esprit de polémique que le crédit
d'impôt compétitivité emploi va
représenter un allègement de charges les
entreprises de 20 milliards
la fameuse tva sociale votée et différée
voulue par le précédent gouvernement rpt
président représenter un allègement
social de 12 milliards et représenter un
coût pour l'état beaucoup plus important
je veux vous rassurer monsieur le
sénateur nous présenterons l'effet de
cette mesure tout au long des débats
budgétaires à venir et vous rendrez
compte que vos présents prévention
d'aujourd'hui était infondée je suis
convaincu que vous soutiendrez avec
ardeur cette mesure dans ses effets est
pour les entreprises de notre pays